okay welcome everyone to the ddps uh
seminar before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics first please mute yourself
during the talk uh but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
audiences so no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out finally The
Talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel so that's about
it let me actually get into the uh
exciting Parts um introducing our
today's speaker um today it is an honor
to host Janson W who is the Robert buer
Collegiate associate professor of
aerospace engineering in the department
of Aerospace and mechanical engineering
at the University of Notre Dame he
earned his PhD in aerospace engineering
from Virginia Tech in 2017 and worked as
a post-doctoral scholar at UC Berkeley
before joining Notre D in
2018 Dr Wang has a multidisiplinary
research background that spans
scientific machine learning the data
assimilations basan Computing
uncertainty quantification and
computational fluid
dynamics his research focuses on
particularly on the indepth integration
of the advanced AIML techniques with
physics based uh mathematical models and
classic numerical methods aiming to
revolutionize the field of computational
modeling in the era of big data and
significantly enhance the predictive
simulation capability he has led
research projects sponsored by multiple
agencies including NSF onl afso darer
and Google and others uh Dr Wang is a
recipient of the 2021 NSF career award
and 2023 onr uh Yip award he is also an
elected vice chair of the US Association
for computational mechanics technical
thrust area on data driven modeling
today um Dr janun Wang will talk about
neural differentiable um physics
unifying numerical pdes and deep
learning for data augmented
computational physics I'm sure we are
going to hear uh a wonderful talk um now
let me um um before I pass the button to
uh him let me ask him a question so that
we we know um you know something about
uh Dr Wang um so my question today is
for you Dr Wang is I happen to know
you're very interested in sketching uh
but for for now you cannot do that
because you're so busy um you know doing
writing all stuff and on on the
computational mechanics and data D
modeling if you can Briefly summarize
how you uh how you got you know where
you are right now from like you know
enormous interest in the
sketching that okay
awesome all right than thank you Yu for
this very kind of introduction so your
question was like a how how am I gonna
so can I I I'm not sure I understand how
how your journey of pursuing the sketch
to where you are right now yeah if you
can briefly describe that yeah yeah so I
I I I learned like painting drawing you
know and in my childhood so actually I
learned that for almost more than 10
years and uh that's kind of uh I I I I
like you know uh to join things uh when
I was a child and that's kind of lead my
uh so when I as I mentioned to you like
when I uh start to choose my my major
and autograph for the autograph majors
and I I I try to study like the
architecture because because I I I think
that's going to leverage my uh kind of
you know this interest in in sketching
and and drawing and uh eventually I got
admitted to like Naval architecture and
ocean engineering so that's a that's
completely different even though they
have like architecture so um and that's
uh uh that's how I started to learn the
fluid mechanics and solid mechanics and
uh and I start you know
kind of learn the the the fluid
competition mechanics and uh that is I
feel like how this my hob been sketching
and lead me to uh a scientist in
competion like competition mechanics in
general and I I spent like the past 10
or 20 years working learning and working
on this area so uh yeah I think I will
still I'm still like doing sketching and
in my spare time
uh so but you know that this is what I'm
currently major when I'm like doing the
competition and coding but yeah that's
very that's very
interesting life path you have taken so
far well thank you so much for sharing
your uh story uh the floor is yours now
okay all right thank you yeah thank you
um so uh uh good afternoon or good
morning depend on where you are so I
know like a lot of people from uh East
Coast or West Coast uh so uh I I would
first like to appre like thank yonsu for
giving me this opportunity and to
present my work uh uh I I'm very excited
about this opportunity to share with you
guys our research on scientific ML and
AI for science um as we know like uh AI
has has been very successful uh in the
past decades especially in the area of
computer vision and natural language
processing um I believe many of you uh
have been using large language models
like uh CH gbt daily um and if you have
a Tesla uh you probably have already
tried their uh full uh self-driving
capability which is kind of cool um I
didn't purchase the but have tried when
they have like free free trial uh so
those are like highly rely on the AI
enabled computer vision uh well in our
group we are interested in how can we uh
leverage the success use Ai and data to
address the scientific challenges and
particularly to advance the
computational science by uh developing
the Next Generation uh data augmented AI
empowered computation modeling and
simulation capabilities uh so in this
talk um I'm going to uh show you some of
our recent Works in this direction and
especially I would like to introduce um
this neuro differenti physics which is a
framework to unify the uh numeric PDS
and deep learning and for uh data
augmented computation modeling for
complex system you know complex the spal
uh temporal physical
phenomena all right um as we know the
computer based modeling and simulation
capabilities uh plays a essential role
for us to understand uh predict and
control um complex system like turbulent
flows flow structure interaction the
thermal fluid coupling and complex
multif physics phenomen during the uh
Advanced manufacturing processes um all
of this uh physical system often uh
exhibit this complex spatial temporal
behaviors and which generally can be
described by a set of partial
differential equations uh which are
known as the governing PDS right so
simulating or predicting this physical
process is basically to obtain the
solution uh of the PD system and by
giving the the the specified initial and
boundary conditions um well this has to
be achieved numerically um where the the
PD are discretized into a big set of
algebraic equations on the discretized
The Domain using like the numerical disg
gradation methods such as finite
difference finite volume or finite
element well depending on um different
numerical method programming languages
or problem of interest there are many
different implementations uh know as
those numerical sofware uh which are
either open source or commercial such as
anus open form phix Abacus well
essential this is uh like from the
traditional perspective to uh talk about
the computational modeling and uh this
Paradigm has been very successful for
the past several decades and people have
used the physics based numeric software
to study the physics and make the
prediction in many applications however
they are also uh face uh some challenges
in in many practical scenarios uh like
if we're consider a very complex uh
systems so usually a complete and
reliable govern equation may not be
fully available uh this is because
either uh like the underlying physics
are too complicated which has not been
fully understood or it is uh because uh
simply like it is invisible to resolve
all the physics for example like we know
um
uh we know like even the most
complicated uh turbulence flows can be
exactly described by never Stokes
equations however it's not feasible to
resolve all the turbulent scale down to
the common growth scales for any flows
with arbitrarily High Ros numbers so we
have to model those uh fluctuations or
small scales using the SGS closures but
what is the true model form of the
closures and what is like the uh true um
constitutive relations those are not
know right and uh uh secondly uh the
input to the models are often uncertain
or even unknown and making the forward
simulation result not reliable here what
I mean by input like the initial
boundary conditions geometries uh those
physical parameters model coefficient so
for instance if we uh try to simulate
like um a patient specific
cardiovascular flows how do we Define
the inflow boundary condition for
different patient and how and and also
like the the material property of the
vessel wall could vary from Patient to
Patient and we cannot easily like do the
mechanical testing for each individual
patient by taking their vessel out right
so uh for those inval patient specific
simulation many input parameters are not
know uh making the forward simulation
you know unreliable and another very
wellknown issue of this conventional
numar Sol is the computational cost so
so basically for um most non-trivial
scenarios this simulation could be
competitional very expensive and make
them not fible for real time or man
quiry applications for example if want
to uh finally achieve digital TRN and we
need the real time predictions and that
is uh able to assimilate data in the
real time so in many uh applications
such as solving like inverse problem uh
dis optimization or or quantifying
uncertainty uh we really need to
repeatly run the forward simulation for
so many times uh so if a single
simulation can take days or weeks
conducting those many inquiry you know
uh applications uh could be impossible
would be impossible well luckily uh we
are in the area of like big data uh
where the uh high resolution
hetrogeneous data um has been like uh
generated daily from either experiments
High FAL simulation or field
observations and also thanks to uh to
the rapid development of uh like the
experimental and simulation techniques
uh and it was see like there's a rapid
development of GPU Hardwares and GPU
Computing and not mentioning the recent
advances in Ai and machine learning uh
so basically uh all of this motivate us
to explore uh maybe like data driven
solutions to address the challenges
discussed uh I discussed above uh in the
uh actually in the in the past few years
there has been a growing trend of
exploring the use of deep learning to
accelerate the simulation or efficiently
like emulate the spatial temporal
physics in a data driven manner as a as
a srate models some of the works show uh
the promise uh uh to a certain extent um
usually I I I I I use the smash gra net
as one of the examples uh it's a uh it's
a a one of the example of this data uh
driven neural Simulator for uh the
spatial temperal physics and uh this is
developed by deite about two years ago
as you can see like uh from this uh
animations the the the same models can
be train to learn the variety of spatial
temporal physics including the solid
deformations uh fluid structure
interactions simple aerodynamics fluid
dynamics this periodic Vortex settings
so the result of usually kind of
impressive compared to like the uh High
Fidelity like numerical reference
however uh their model structure is
quite simple uh which is not nothing but
a message passing graph neuron to
capture the dynamic transition of the
state from current step uh to The Next
Step uh which is trained in a data
driven way so conceptually uh this is
simply to train a blackbox neuron
Network to learn the transition from UT
to ut+ one use tons of labels of this T
to t+1 pairs right so once trained and
given the initial condition the model
can autor regressively you know draw out
and predict the Dynamics and and this
Auto regressive U model evaluation we us
call uh model roll out uh so this type
of model is a simplest P data driven uh
Next Step neural predictor or you can
call it like a neural operator because
you're learning those operator defined
from T to T plusform um so we actually
uh work with deep M uh like the Toby as
the first author of this mesh net to
test the model on a few simple fluid
dynamics problem so here I'm I'm showing
like the the cylinder flows uh which has
the periodic Vex shutting as you can see
that uh the mass net predictions after a
longterm uh roll out uh still uh looks
very physical however compared to cfy
reference the face is actually
completely opposite so if you check the
history of the dry coefficient uh where
the green light is the mesh net and blue
one is the reference well the prediction
capture uh the overall like Behavior Uh
so from transition stage to the uh per
periodic votex shatting stage there's a
clear uh uh phase shift uh can be seen
and uh this um this is actually very
simple case um since eventually Dynamic
become periodic which is not so hard to
capture you data driven matter right so
if we move to a slightly like more
challenging scenarios where we consider
a channel um uh and uh and we put a jet
at the inlet so the angle of jet can
change over time so it'll create a
slightly more complicated Vex Dynamics
as as you can see at the beginning the
the data driven like neuros simulator
can capture the Dynamics reasonably well
but quickly they becomes noisy and
eventually not physical at all uh well
we know uh this is due to the issue of
this next Auto regressive models since
Arrow will be accumulated during this
model r u so we always see um the poor
robustness of this models for long-term
model R especially when the Dynamics
become more chaotic ter and turbulent
right another issue for this uh Pur data
truth model is the the generalizability
in other of training regimes so when
testing the model on completely
different like new initial b condition
boundary condition new parameters like
Renos numbers uh which are far from your
training range and the prediction could
go uh wrong easily so the question is
how to improve uh you may see that okay
the the current uh Next Step model
formulation seems quite simple and
definitely this can be improved with
more advanced sequence model like using
the memories like lstm or uh incorporate
like temporal tensions and make it more
like a Transformer uh like model uh we
have done that um and and improve the M
gra net using like the temporal like
Transformers and graphing coding and it
did improve the result for example if
you see the orange light here in this
figures so they actually have a better
uh agreement with the the the reference
uh but still the main issue of the PO
robustness uh uh and and and
generalizability there still exist uh I
don't think it by simply like changing
the neural architectures would uh
completely solve the the the the issue
of data driven models so let's think
about what we did so far so up to here
we completely like rely on data and
everything essentially is a black box
right um well
so however um we're not completely uh
blind to the system we try to model so
we usually have some PR knowledge about
the underlying physics uh namely uh we
know the uh governing uh physics
represented by the PD is to certain
extent uh although as I mentioned before
the governing PDS may not be you know
fully avail able uh complete so some por
is uncertain or unknown such as some
constitutive relation closure terms and
some complex uh physical process that
the mechanic behind it is is not know so
we can't we don't have a uh like a
physical description of those uh cing or
sometime we just cannot computation
resolve everything and we have to uh you
know we we cannot basically resolve uh
some part we cannot resolve so uh this
overall this physical prior is kind of I
call kind of vague um now the question
is how can we uh how can we leverage
this incomplete and big physics to
enable a better data driven
modeling uh so when people talk about
like physics in formed learning uh one
popular way of using the physical eyes
well we can use that to regularize the
model training process namely we can
pany the violation of the physical law
uh or constraints by incorporating the
residual of the C equation
into the L function and which
essentially just regiz the neuron
natural training and this is a general
idea of physics informed neur netor for
Ping right a lot of work has been done
in this directions including our group
uh we have also contribut to this areas
many years ago um however uh no issue
for for p the nonar is introduced by the
PD loss and also this multiobjective
optimization you have many terms in the
law
and make the training uh more difficult
and in many complex scenarios that the
basically cannot be trained while to get
uh converged Solutions and more
importantly um uh as I mentioned here we
are talking about the scenario that the
the physics prior is kind of V is kind
of vag namely that like the governing
PDS is only partial no uh for example we
only roughly know well this process is
diffusion dominant and uh there's a lot
of like unknown things um it's not
possible to formulate like clear like uh
this uh physics informed a lot since the
complete uh model form of the PD
residual is is not known so in this talk
I would like to introduce a different
idea of um how can we integrate the
physics into the data driven like deep
learning models uh instead of using the
government equation to regularize the
neuron exra training in a soft manner
like the
we are trying to uh integrate the PD
operators uh in the uh in the partial no
governing equation as a part of the the
neuron Network
architectures well this is motivated by
the the foundational relationship uh
between the neuronal architectural
component and numeric pde uh operators
uh which can uh which has been uh
recently actively uh explored in uh in
the Deep learning uh Community uh what I
mean by like NE Architectural Components
are those like building blocks for deep
learning architecture such as uh with
residual block residual connections
convolutions graph kernels M passing
attention mechanisms recurrent
structures and and and and so on right
so this can be kind of linked back to
the PD operators and their numerical
representations like those uh different
numeric schemes
uh so here let me give you some examples
to make it more concrete uh so in in the
architecture of the wellknown U uh Ras
net right so this is a very uh famous
like um neur neuron asberg architectures
which are constructed by uh many uh
residual blocks and in this residual
blocks the RAS connection is is basic
building blocks uh which was proposed to
solve the vanishing gradient issues
originally so conceptually the the
residual connections um layer simply
take like the the current state UT right
and apply the transformation function
with the neural network like the
trainable neural functions and add the
output back to the original state and
this process can be interpreted as a
discret approximation of OD using the
for forward Oiler scheme so depending on
the trained neural functions and we can
always find a corresponding continuous
Odes uh accordingly so reversely uh we
can use this uh continuous OD to Define
this res residual connections which
essentially has infinite number of
layers or it has infinite deaths and
this analogy between the res connection
and Odes has inspired the creation of a
new class of the raset architecture know
as the neural Odes and which has been
like kind of a popular in in in the Deep
Learning Community as well in the past
few
years uh well another example is uh like
the mathematical Foundation of
convolution or n so the convolution
layers right so if you think about the
spatial PD operators such as like
diffusions and can be approximated using
like a finite difference see let's see
if we use cental difference or the
system actually Define a convolution
kernel right and and the PD operators
can be interpreted as The convolution
Operators and namely the standard
convolution operators can be linked to
the finite difference based spatial PD
operators on the uniform grades so NPD
operators such as diffusion convection
gradient and can be expressed as
convolution operations uh and the
convolution caros um reversely can be
interpreted as a uh one of the spatial
uh differential terms and with certain
discretization uh schemes well this
relation can be extended to like uh
irregular domains or like nonan space uh
by linking the graph comption oper
operators with uh for example finite
volume based spatial
differentiations and more examples uh
include like the relationship between
the recurrent Network structures and
with controlled differential equations
and implicit schemes and and just to
name a few and and if you think about
the the temporal tensions and it can be
uh inter interpret with the like high
order uh uh time stampings so so here uh
let's go back to our goal is we we would
like to build a sequence neuron networ
such as com STM for example to to learn
the the spatial temporal physics and
rely on data so we're still like trying
to develop a data Dr model okay um like
we want to build a Comm ldm and to this
sequence model and to learn the data and
and build this Auto request model so if
we know the complete uh like form of the
true government equations and we can
choose to build this RN completely based
on uh uh this pdes meaning uh like those
convolution Kels R connections and
recurrent structures can be completely
determined by the PD operators
with with specified disg gradations and
in this way it's basically nothing but a
numerical solver right so um so from the
neuron netor point of view the
conventional numar solver is one special
instance of the neuron netor just the
all this parameters are determined by
human knowledge right so we don't need
to learn those are determined by the PD
we know numerical schemes that we
developed in the past decades and inall
instead of from training data however as
as I mentioned before like the the the
true government equation often partially
no and or some cases even the no um we
know the the complete equations the the
because the the conventional numer
scheme can lead to a solver to be
computationally very expensive or
sometime very unstable uh so some part
of the equations uh for example are very
challenged to solve um any of those
scenarios can be described as this we
have the Govern equations well the some
portion of of it like the K is is no
some portion of it like U as unknown and
comping between those uh between them
could could also be unknown nonlinear
functional or
operators now we can leverage this V
physics to redesign this reiring network
unit and to form a PD integrated comp
lstn for the spatial temporal itions and
for example we can uh directly encode uh
the PD operator such as convection
diffusion the pressure gradient in the
partial know like govern equation as a
part of the the neuron architecture
based on the relationship as I just
discussed um essentially we built a
hybrid com lstm with fixed uh and both
fixed and trainable parts and the entire
model is is fully differentiable
allowing a holistic model training so
this still can be viewed as neuronetwork
trained like a neuron networks and so
this can be viewed as ml enhance the
solver but it's Way Beyond the solare
since it has a strong flexibility so uh
we can build um using like Advanced deep
learning architecture for example with
this long shortterm memories and with
the tension mechanism so so many design
that you can U actually
possible decide that you can you can you
can do within this uh framework so this
is uh this like a neuro differentiable
physics framework and which actually
provide a differentiable programming
platform to allow the uh same less and
flexible blend of the incomplete physic
component and trainable neural
architecture component to form a novel
like neuros sofware like I said that the
design of the uh this neuros software is
very flexible uh so let me uh show you
just one of them um to kind of showcase
the idea so let's build a commm network
to learn the spatial temporal dynamics
of fluid flows so with first to decide
the um the this next step like learning
unit and for the sequence net and
capturing the transition of the State uh
between two learning steps right so to
make the neuros software fast the the
learning step dity is much greater than
typical
uh numerical time stab 100,000 times
times bigger and the learning unit is
operating uh on a very coarse resolution
so we're actually developing a a very uh
low resolution models and which is
efficient and we have uh uh three like
constitutional resal blocks
corresponding to convection diffusion
and pressure gradient and uh connected
to like non-trainable convolution visual
blocks which are actually determined by
those PD operators and a component
between those components are based on
like uh the momentum equation so overall
it's it's a it's a convolution res
blocks in formed by the never St
equations and to enable the a high
resolution prediction a super resolving
conditional generative diffusion models
combined uh which I I'm going to uh
discuss this uh later in detail in the
second part of my talk uh but before we
move to U like using this PD integrated
recurrent unit to build a Comm lsdm
Network let's just test the Merit of
integrating this this PD op by only use
this learning unit and as an one step
predictors and we can compare it with uh
like the on step predictor with same
Comm res Network structures but
everything is trainable and to make the
comparison fair so the netal structure
size are exactly same and only
differences one is blackbox and one is
hybrid so we use the same flow problem
as I showed before and to do the
comparison and both models are trained
over different like um uh jet position
and Ros number so here I'm showing you
two testing samples where the jat uh
position and the Ros number are
different and uh which are not seen
during the training so the left is a
little bit like lower Renos number and
uh the right is a little higher uh which
is 10,000 and the first row of is is is
a cfd reference and metal is our PD
integrate Next Step NE our predictor and
last row is the pure blackbox Baseline
so again as you can see the blackbox
basine uh can actually capture the
Dynamics at the beginning and then it
will become pretty noisy and un physical
and clearly showing the series the error
accumulations and this issue become uh
more serious for the high Renos number
case as you can see um however uh this
PD integrated models on the country are
almost like identical to the to the
reference even after long-term model Ro
so this figure showing you the eror
propagation over the model Ro steps and
the model is evaluated over many uh
different Ros number and different jaet
position that's why you see the scalling
because for some testing scenarios they
have higher eror some have lower so from
the arrow propagation figures we find
that the the blackbox Baseline this
orange uh the will like uh basically
dominant by the arrows especially after
the extrapolations well our PD
integrated one has almost like barely
see the error accumulations and uh more
you can see the the blackbox baselight
has very large scattering over different
testing cases indicating a poor
robustness well our model is is
relatively more robust as the arrow
scattering remains very low so the the
comparison of The Next Step neural uh
predictor shows the Merit of integrating
the uh the Govern PDS and the the
architecture inform formed by by the
government equations uh and in uh to
design this recurrent learning unit and
then we can use this uh uh recurrent
unit and to form a a sequence model so
like uh based on this uh uh PD
integrated learning unit for example we
can first formulate this reir uh neuron
networks and then we can introduce the
trainable hidden state to learn the long
shortterm memories and which lead to a c
lstm uh Network so compared to the
blackbox lstm the the the governing PDS
of the fluid flows actually embeded
Blended um as as I show like uh
conceptually in this yellow box so we
can uh make this model to be sequence to
sequence and and the laws can be defined
on this roll out trajectory instead of
uh uh doing like the next step uh teer
forcing training so this requires the
gradient uh that can be back propagated
over the entire neuros software
including like all this of course neuron
nwor and and also like the uh the solver
component so the entire model is is
building uh uh using the differentiable
differentiable programming and uh we use
the jaxs and we also use Pyar so here we
we we use the jack to enable the the
differentiable
programming uh so we can use this uh P
integrated con valm Network to learn and
predict the 2D Force the homogeneous
isotropic tulas uh namely the common
growth flows so the gr choose is uh
generated using the DNS on the very F
FES 2048 Cube uh uh square and uh we
want to build a very efficient data
driven reduce water models operating in
a very Co spatial temporal resolutions
like 64 60 by 64 which is 32 times
downscaled in each dimensions and the
time step is the 32 times of the numeric
steps but the training range is from 0
to 800 learning steps and uh we test
model first we test model to do the
forecast like time forecast from a to uh
800 to 1600 um and the the second column
is a PD integrated com STM the third one
is third column is a blackbox compound
SDM as you can see both model can can
forecast in time and the prediction are
reasonably well and if you compare the
two data driven models uh well the
blackbox model is is uh slightly less
accurate uh because you can see more
noise in the forecasting regions in
comparison like uh the middle uh one is
agree with the reference very well even
at a very uh last step after 100 uh like
1600 model roll out steps so in this
case the the the the current equation is
actually no it's is n Stu and you may
Wonder uh what if I just rely on the
physics without neuron natural component
uh what will happen so the last column
showing you the result of purely like a
never Stoke solver um even with the SGS
model because the the matches two cores
uh so the prediction has large discrimin
compared to the reference um indicating
that this purely using the the Govern
equation won't work in such a core
spatial tempor resolutions and this
actually can be viewed as the
traditional Lees but on a very course uh
spatial temporary resolutions um lastly
uh I'm I'm I'm showing you the aror
propagation plot uh for those three
models uh so we just look at this two
data driven models uh the green light
shows the error propagation for the the
black box Al conv valum and the arror is
climbing up quickly and and also we see
the large scattering which is consistent
to the previous case and with the blue
light we we can see the AR is uh error
accumulation issues can be significant
mate um by integrating the the uh like
convetion diffusion those charms into
the uh neuron netor architectures so in
the previous slides the model is test on
to forecasting time but U it actually
start roll out from the initial
condition which is which is which is
used for training so here we we make the
testing more challenging and now we test
the model just start from a randomly
generated initial conditions okay which
has not been seen during training and
and and the models can uh models this
time will let them to roll out for a
much longer range like 32 uh learn uh
100 learning steps corresponding to
51,000 uh the mark steps so given the a
randomly generated uh like new initial
conditions uh you can see now the the
pure blackbox uh Baseline completely
fell because the predicted flow patterns
are significant uh significant deviate
from the the reference even in the
second row um and uh and it becomes
completely different for the longer term
uh like rod for the long longer roled
lens well in contrast uh so this PD
integrated model can actually capture
the the Dynamics uh even after like uh
32 uh 100 uh row out steps again like
pure alvs solvers it fails at this
resolutions because most the flow
features has been damped out so as show
in this Arrow propagation figures the uh
the difference between the the PD inte
to the conm and its Black Box
counterpart is is much more sign
significant show showing like much
better generalizability and robustness
uh in this like more like testing uh
scenarios uh so simil framework can be
used to design the uh differentiable
hybrid neuros Sol for the fluid
structure interacting Dynamics again uh
we build this physics integrate qu Val
TM Network to emulate uh the space faal
uh temporal FSI phenomena uh in contrast
to the like pure uh blackbox comat LM uh
so we encode the fsds into the recurring
unit at the fixed convolutions and
interaction between fluid and structure
actually enforced using the uh immerse
boundary method uh the entire neuros
solver is fully vectorized the fully
differentiable and which is Implement
Jacks so it can Leverage The GPU
Computing and can be trained as as
Network so uh uh we showcase the model
using two class class classic FSI
problem when Vortex indu vibration and
others uh flow over flexible beams um I
don't want to spend too much time to you
know go over this again but I'm I'm just
want to quickly to show you that similar
Behavior as you can see um the arrow
accumulation and the robustness uh for
the blackbox models and can be
significantly improved and for uh using
this uh this hybrid uh learning
structures and U uh and and also like uh
uh here I also want to see like U uh
people may think like conceptually the
ml is kind of serving as a correction
term or like closure model what if I
separately train a neuron n to learn the
discrepancy from the data and then embed
it back to the PD solware to correct it
and I call this as a wely coupled uh
like weekely coupled neurop PD solware
as you can see it is not stable uh at uh
which uh so the last column uh it will
quickly blow up so stability issue of
this weekly couped approach has been
also reported in like data driven turbin
closure turbance moding Community uh as
well and uh moreover like if we loosely
coupled the the the solware and neuron
Network the flexibility is so limited
since the solware has to follow all the
numerical rules and it cannot be
formulated as lstm right uh so here I
would like to emphasize this neuro
differential model is not simply to
embed neur n into a traditional numeric
solare it's completely like we're
developing a new like uh uh newer
networks beyond the sofware so uh here
uh here I'm I'm showing you like the the
model uh can even be tested on like a
you know with the different sprin
stiffness for this V case uh so this
time the this this this spring stiffness
has not been seen during training so uh
if we just do the pure data driven
blackbox model it will completely fail
because it cannot generalize to out of
the training conditions uh but you can
see um uh this approach the second
column still very accurate capture the
Dynamics and agree with the reference
very well and so in this case um you can
you can see like the uh at the beginning
the the arror is is going up and and
also the for the structure Dynamics is
simply
that uh so for the second case basically
devel similar message and I'm going to
for the sake of time I'm going to skip
it and the competition cost of course is
case dependent if we set a cost of open
form um for the the high fedal
simulation on CPUs as a baseline uh our
fully vectorized solver on GPU without
neuron Network can already be very fast
for the 2D Viv cases has s seven times
speed up well with the neuronal
component uh like both data Dr models
matter blackbox rep PD integrated the
speed up is over 50 times and for
turbulence case since the the DS more
costly so speed up is more significant
well the the training of this model is
typical comparable to the conducting a
single hypat simulations in terms of a
wartime um however uh like once a model
Trend and we can enjoy like the fast
beat up for performing like new
simulations for example with random
generate initial conditions different
modeling parameters so as you can see
the the this neur differential model
framework allow us to blend the physics
uh with the Deep learning to build a
novel hybrid neural models and there are
much more like interesting D beyond what
have just showed so if we have
sufficient training data but very
limited knowledge and this framework
turns to be like you know this Advanced
deep learning uh like uh framework uh
since you can use all the like Advanced
deep learning uh architectures and
component if we move to the uh the other
end where we have no data so the the
neuron uh netork has to be completely
determined by the physics so now the the
neural defens model becomes a tradition
Mark solver however the solver are
Implement in a deep learning manner
means like they are fully differentiable
and they they they they are fully
factorized so they can elaborate GPU
Computing which also significantly
Advanced the the field of scientific
Computing and and modeling so for
example we have developed a couple of
solvar like the GPU accelerate
differentiable cfd and FSI solvers in
Jacks and we call it def flow FSI which
is fully vectorized and fully
differentiable and they very fast on
gpus uh like a DS simulation for turban
Channel flows with 8 million Mash cells
uh which going to take about 60 hours
using open form on 32 CPUs course for
one flow through time and but with our
Jax uh s uh the Jack differentiable
solware only need two hours less than
two hours on one a100
a6000 uh gpus um and since it's fully
differentiable the the solware can be
easily du the forward and inverse
problem since it it can be trained like
neuron networks right so the gradient
can be propagated to anywhere within the
solare so uh for example if the I know
stiff uh physical parameters such as
stiffness in the Viv case um it can be
inferred uh using the gradient based
optimization so by default it has haton
capabilities so using the uh
differentiable uh neural Paradigm we're
working on like different scientific
problems and each of them has its own
special uh features and unique challenge
Alles and for example we developed the
Jack spased GPU accelerate
differentiable uh solve for the pho
Bosman transport equations which are
high dimensional PDS and for nanoscale
thermal uh transport um so leveraging
tensor Computing and we we can
demonstrate massive scalabilities and we
are also working on modeling you know
different manufacturing process where
the data are limited and and the physics
are not fully understood uh since uh
today the time is a limit uh I'm going
to spend the last um maybe 10 minutes on
focus on turbulence which we know is
it's a very challenge system and also
consistent to the result what I what I
have showed so far so to obtain like the
spatial temporal instantaneous turbulent
flows uh requires addtive resolving
simulation like you have to do the DNS L
yes which are extremely expensive right
uh so many people have tried to emulate
the spatial temporal behaviors uh
turbulent behaviors using deep burning
so for example caming develop this next
stab seeing Auto encoder to autor
regressively emulate the spatial
temporal turbulence for the inflow
generations and this model can be
extended to uh like using more advanced
sequence model like Transformers and our
groups also like develop the graph based
the Transformer and to enable like the
turbulent simulation on the all
structure grades and like I in the
previous slides I've show you like this
PD integrated Comm LM to predict the
homogeneous uh isotropic turbulance so
conceptual all this model can be
summarized as a following structure so
you have a type of like CN or GN or even
pod based uh Auto encoder to encode the
high dimensional flow into Laten space
and then you kind of use the sequence
Network to learn the latent Dynamics in
autoquest manner so the model I
formulate in this deterministic manner
and training is is basically to minimize
the mismatch and between like the with
the the DS instantaneous flow uh labels
uh so the the the model is formulated in
the deterministic matters and and train
to minimize uh the the the mismatch with
Ds label therefore uh we are trying to
learn the distant
dist uh deterministic transition from uh
the DNS instantaneous flow data and then
propo kind of in time however we know
the turbulent flow is inherent
stochastic um uh like uh one DS
trajectory reference just one
realizations and there are many possible
realizations from same stat stochastic
process that follow the same turbulent
statistics right so a deterministic
model can only at best to reproduce one
particular realizations and cannot
generalize to different uh cannot like
to to generate other like different
realizations under the same probability
distributions and also like because the
chaotic nature of the turban flow and it
actually poses a significant challenge
for this autor regressive uh model
training and and predictions well
alternatively uh you may think why not
just use uh match some statistics of the
DNS data instead of using the
instantaneous flow uh to train a model
such as like the mean or Ral stresses
however just having the model to learn a
few uh statistic cannot guarantee you're
going to learn the same or like physical
uh coherent flow structures uh for
example even the two flows have the same
mean flow profiles instantaneous
coherent structure can be entirely
different so ideally we want to
understand the probability distribution
of the turb system however this is like
the flow is 40 spatial temporal
stochastic process which say extremely
high Dimensions think about uh the
dimension could be like the number of
times St times the number of grade
points um uh often reach up to like 10
to4 * 10 to7 so to determine this
probability density landscape as
invisible well thanks to the recent
advances in the generative AI which is
cause of the unsupervised storing
approach it provide a way to implicitly
extract the distribution from the uh
observe realizations allowing the
generation of new samples that follow
the uh same probability distributions so
in the recent recent years uh our group
have developed the generative AI based
models for uh the spatial temporal
instantaneous turbulence
Generations um just show you like some
example in one of our early work uh this
is done by uh my student Looney who is
currently is also in uh leore National
Lab uh so
uh so he used the normalizing flow
couple with the graph encoded
Transformer to learn the uh and generate
the spatial temporal turbulent flows and
normalizing flow transform a simple
distribution into a complex one through
a series invertible Transformations
allowing us to learn the uh the complex
PD PDF of the flow at each time step so
using this uh we can generate many
different realizations of the separated
flows and which each individ like
instantaneous flow field are differing
from others however the statistics of
this flows agree with the L reference um
and we also can plot a single point uh
velocity PDF at different locations and
so basically the uh the PDF uh represent
by the rine match the Lees the black
dash line reasonably well uh showing it
can capture the stochastic behaviors of
the flow system however the no issue of
this naline in flow is a scalability and
make it challenge to apply to the very
large scale real words through 3D or 4D
turbulence and later we develop a uh
this spatial temporal generative model
using the probability uh probabilistic
diffusion based techniques which has
been very successful uh in the computer
vision and AGI Community uh so like the
those generator you know like SAR they
are based on the score matching model
this type of score
uh the concept is very simple so we
transform the samples from a no
distribution like like a gaan into uh to
the one uh from arbitrary like uh Target
distributions um through a diffusion
process so after training uh we can
basically generate the Y noise uh this y
noise field is sampled and then
gradually denoised using this learned
reverse uh transition kernel eventually
form a physical field so our model can
directly handle theace spal temporal
data with 3D convolutions and enable
generating a short spatial temporal flow
samples and and this work has been uh
published in the cmme but uh the problem
is in the memory footprint because uh
it's actually a bottleneck you cannot
really generate a very large scale like
DNS level uh turbulence so recently we
developed this conditional neurofield uh
a a latent diffusion model to achieve
the same goal but in a more scalable
manners so the the concept is we use the
condition neuro field or neuro implicit
representations and for Dimension
deductions and encode a high dimensional
flow field into the low dimensional
Laten space and in contrast to the CN or
GN Auto encoders this neurofield offer
the higher compression ratios and it's
mashing dependent so you can handle any
arbitary geometries with unst structure
mhes and within the latent space and we
do the diffusion and to uh enable
the to enable enable uh the generation
of the latent uh State and which can be
then decoded back to the uh spatial
temporal like physical space and use the
the conditioner field again and this
allow us to generate a very Vivid um
instantaneous turbulent realizations
which are different from each other uh
but they look similar to the DS although
this instantaneous flow realization are
different from each other and you can
see the statistics of this generated uh
spatial temporal flow samples I exactly
agree with the with the DNS uh say like
the mean flow V turbulence fluctuations
and two point correlations um and uh to
further test the model so we can use the
generative uh the flows and to fit in
another like a down frame adding
resolving simulations so if the
generated flow of structures is physical
and it's going to uh the the down frame
uh turbine simulations there's no Decay
otherwise uh the the turbulence will
Decay so we compare our models with the
DS precursor which is like a reference
and also the one of the state of art
deep learning based uh synthetic inflow
generators and you can clearly see that
uh their models the terance will Decay
but for ours it actually remain this uh
the same similar uh terance intensity as
the as the DN reference so I'm going to
skape those uh quantitative and show you
like a couple more result in two minutes
so we can now handle like more
challenging case like flow separations
with the irregular geometries where the
CN doesn't work and as you can see here
our confu can generate very diverse spal
temporal flow
realizations um and you barely can see
the difference uh of those which is DNS
which is generated um so the first one
is DNS the other three are generary
samples and although the the
instantaneous flow of each samples are
different from each other their
turbulent statistics such a me and Ral
stresses TK are same and this is another
more challenging flows involves the
turbulent boundary layers and with um
Regular roughness elements and showing
this 4D spatial temporal Generations
again you can see the the generated
spatial temporal turbin are pretty
similar to the DS and also have the
correct
statistics uh so I'm going to skip the
computational cost and if you're
interested I can talk about but here I
just want to highlight the it's to
generate this compared to simulators
we're going to gain a significant speed
up and and I want to use two like to
wrap up this talk is I show you like our
conf can once this train it can generate
diverse real like spatial temporary
realizations uh and which are different
from each other however the most
exciting part of this model is a
conditional generation meaning give us
specific conditions the trend model can
generate that particular realization
corresponding to the uh condition that
uh we provide so here are uh some
examples of the condition
uh for example um if I put a few sensors
in this flow and to measure the
instantaneous velocity at as sparse
locations and then our confuted models
can immediately reconstruct the
fullfield uh instantaneous flows in the
spatial temporal manners and or if we
can possibly have the low resolution
scans of the flows as conditions uh this
is quite typical in the cardiovascular
or uh applications like uh people using
the flow MRA and get some low resolution
datas and then we can generate high
resolution spatial temporal floats and
that particular realizations another
interesting scenario we do the low dat
simulation such as Ur which is super
fast and we can conditionally generate
um the those turbulent structures uh and
make it like a high resolution uh Lees
like result um all of this can be done
uh using our like a basan posterior
sampling of our trained uh diffusion
models without the need of through rate
training so meaning our unconditional
trained uh confute models can be used to
generate those uh the realizations
corresponding to the condition um you
provide um in the zero shot so uh let me
uh show you at the example remember like
this uh this separate flows um and was
uh within the this uh Channel with the
periodic heels right so if we this time
we put a few like sensors in the uh uh
in a several like sparse locations and
to measure the instantaneous velocity
only on the sparse locations and this
time you can see those all the Genera
samples the spatial temperal s there
looks exactly the same as as as the as
our as the flow that we are you know
observing so this is very exciting
because um we can basically reconstruct
the spatial temporal flows and the
instantaneous flows and using this
approach and and similarly uh remember
like a previously the gener sample they
are uh very diverse uh they are
different realization but if we put the
sensors in the flows and for this 40
generation and you can see with only
very Spar sensors and we and reconstruct
the uh the the flows and even the
instantaneous flows and looks pretty
similar to the flow that uh that we are
uh observing we we're
measuring so uh a little bit like
parametric study if we have just one
sensor and you can see uh this time all
the generative samples kind of like
scattered right so because the the
condition information is so limited but
we increase the number of sensors and
all the uh generate scatter samples that
kind of converge into the particular
realizations that you are observing and
even with noise it's pretty robust and
this is a another example of this uh uh
super resolution uh Generations
similarly we can condition on like a
different low resolution even like this
like four pixel so we still have this uh
uh accurate statistics but if we have a
more like more informative low
resolution so you can see the the
generally high resolution not only the
statistic but the the realization uh
like the instantaneous flow they they
almost like the same all right so I
think I'm going to stop here and uh
happy to take any
questions well thank you so much for the
wonderful talk uh Janson uh let's have a
Q&A sessions okay we have a three or
four questions in the chat uh the first
one is from theant uh he's asking are
your jack silers available on
GitHub uh we haven't we haven't uh uh so
yeah it's going to be available but uh
we we haven't uh so we're working on the
the manuscript so once we we we get it
out we will make an open source thank
you uh the second question is by David
could you comment on the energy cost of
your training
plus inference of your neural models
versus running an equivalent cftd
simulation yeah so I think uh yeah let
me pull up that slides um so like I
mentioned the the the the training uh so
the it's it's actually depend on like
what cases you are talking about overall
like the the training cost uh for
example for this uh FSI case it's
comparable to uh conducting a single FSI
simulation so
uh so basically the the inference like
speed up is like this so you can imagine
like your training models and if you
just only use it once and that's going
to be this kind of a slightly have
higher overhead if you just run this
once but if you're trying them out it's
going to tell like do the inference give
a different initial condition different
material properties and for many many
times okay because of the
speed up and that will like uh kind of
um you will gain a lot of U saving for
the computational cost right so it's
really about like the the the the
testing scenario so but here I'm I'm
just showing you like the the training
of the the models is like uh for for the
two examples is kind of comparable to
like doing one hyp simulation okay so
what you're saying here is um you didn't
include the cost of generating data in
the training as a training cost but even
though even though you do that right
right so so yeah that's that's a good
question I I forgot to mention that so
like for uh for the uh the FSI case I
just generate like uh uh two data set
because because uh it's actually we have
a lot of physics here so you can think
this this this hyper model is not
completely blackbox that is one like we
test on a different like material
property like the spring stiffness it
actually work because we have those
physical component there in the model so
yeah we the we we only have a very
limited training data in in in that in
that sense it's not completely like a
black B that's why like when we do the
uh testing or like given different Ros
number different like material property
the the data driven model is completely
fail but if you include a lot of
training data like in the par parameter
space I believe the the the the blackbox
models can be improved as well it's just
that those data are so
limited yeah yeah okay um next question
is by
Seer is saying thank you for the great
presentations have you applied your
method to any examples involving 4D
spatial temporal problems with known
physics uh
yeah so Ford uh So currently we are
doing like a lot of my uh uh like
applications are turbulent flow they are
those are like 4D right so spatial
temporal and it's a 3D so uh we uh we we
we are working on like CLE this neural
software and with the Genera model so
here like like those uh this cases those
are like 40 right uh but I haven't like
really showed you the C polling of um so
what what we are doing actually I can
show this
slides so it's kind of this is something
that we already uh put it on archive but
we are doing like the 4D version of the
so basically we have the physics inform
like the neural software and to do like
the low resolution uh which capture like
the geometry dependent flow features and
because that is very difficult to to
learn you need a lot of data and to to
generalize right so that is actually
from this hybrid solver which just has
some physics and we also have like a
conditional generative models to
generate those High resolu uh small
scale high high wave number high
frequency features and and and on
condition on the the low resolution like
flow solware output So eventually we can
get this very uh high resolution uh
predictions um and with a very low cost
so here is the energy Spectrum as you
can see like the the the full like a
spectrum uh um like uh this black Dash
SL this is a DNS if we only do like I
didn't put Lees so L going to be like
stop at certain wave number because you
didn't resolve it and also uh you have
uh you have some discriminan because uh
the the ls is uh because of a closure
model and also like a course match right
uh but was this part and we can make
this part accurate uh but you still like
stop here but with the conditional
generations and we actually can recover
the and and almost the entire Spectrum
like this Ry uh well um if you just
simply do like the super resolution like
uh by cubic this the feature going to be
completely wrong I'm just here showing
you like the refence yes uh back to the
question that we are kind of like doing
this on the uh four 4D uh turbulence
boundary layers and and we also generate
uh uh a very high resolution DNS
database for the turbine boundary layers
and with different you know pressure
gradient and with different Ros numbers
and we actually develop models and on
that um cool yeah cool um so related
questions um from me would be there are
many
pdes uh which is you know even more than
40 uh when you com uh do the space
tempal like the veloc equations it could
be 60 plus times 7D and then if you go
to um you know particle transport uh
equations it can go like you know all
the Angles and uh it can be higher and
higher so so if that can if your method
can be extended to those higher yeah
sure no problem so actually we have we
have a similar problem like I mentioned
here we we we have another solver and we
I'm going to submit a paper like
probably next week so this is uh solving
the the the phono Bossman transfer
equation so it is a high dimensional PD
is not just about space and time we also
have the the frequency band angles of
the the the phos and so it's actually
like it can go up like to to eight or 10
Dimensions so uh those are like high
dimensional PDS and and and we are uh we
develop a Jax uh differentiable solver
for that and uh and uh the software is
also like fully like vectorized and and
we're also kind of adding like tensor
tensor Computing component to that
software but now the the software is is
very scalable and we can uh do like the
steady state and the transient phono
transport uh phono Bosman transport uh
simulations on the transistor so the
very regular oh by the way this sare is
is is also like on structure so we can
handle very uh uh like complex geometri
so we actually simulate the the the heat
transfer in the in the complex the
transistor uh for the computer chips and
study the Nanos scale heat transfer that
that is a high dimensional P all right
super nice very nice uh okay next
question is by Jun gang uh he said
thanks for the presentation Dr Wang is
your model relies on adjacent data pairs
to train XT and xt+ one in that case
wouldn't the addor accumulate when doing
recursive predictions did you consider
longer data pairs to train yeah actually
uh so what what I'm showing you is uh is
like this next step we we uh here when
we I'm showing you like when I uh uh try
to see like why this uh like was this uh
like PD informed structure compared to
everything is trainable and I just want
to show you like using this approach and
even we build a next St models and we
have a much better performance in terms
of the error accumulation so we can
medigate the arror accumulation
significant compared to the blackbox you
are right so if you just like do the
teacher forcing blackbox and you have a
significant eror accumulations but even
like we formulate same thing like next
step models this explicit time stamping
right so the the AR accumulation is is
is there is some Arrow accumulation uh
but it's it's very minor but this is not
ultimate form of the model so you can
use that to construct like the the the
more uh like Advanced the sequence model
like the here I'm showing you the com
STM that so actually we're using the
entire trajectory so not entire but
longer trajectory to to do this sequence
to sequence training instead of teacher
forcing so that is why we have to make
this entire things to be differentiable
because if your loss is based on not
just the one like T to t plus one it's
actually T T1 T3 T4 so you have to make
sure that your gradient can be
propagated to throw this Recon structure
right so so every component they have to
be differentiable so then you can do the
back propagations so that is why it's
very important uh uh this this for this
differentiable programming using the
differentiable programming okay answer
the question all right uh next question
is phal he's asking generative models
are expensive to train and require lots
of data any idea on incorporating
physics in your generative model yes um
that's that's that's good question so
basically the generative model is is is
expensive uh to train and actually we
find that uh so try to avoid
memorizationscripture
uh training data is not that as much as
what they need like for the general
purpose generating model but still uh we
we we we need a lot of data so that's
why uh at the very last slides I I just
show you like we're trying to kind of
Leverage like this physics uh hybrid
physics neural solvers and as a base and
we use that to kind of simulate large uh
scale flow structure and on top it we
generate small scale so the reason is
that the small scale uh flow structures
especially when the the flow structures
like turbine structures go to like uh
common growth we know it's Universal
Universal across the different all the
different flows so that means you have a
lot of data so everybody generate like a
high FL simulations and for different
cases and and if we only look at the
small scale so those are the data is
huge and but the the the problem is um
we we we we want to coup it with like a
more physics uh informed or physics
integrated like uh a software that can
uh U roughly accurately capture like the
the large scale structures which is more
like geometry and Boundary condition
dependent and so that that is the the uh
what we are doing and maybe the next
step we are working on all right uh next
question is by Rick he said nice talk
can you comment on the training
requirements data time for the last
present it results like stochastic
modeling of Trent turbulence
MH so actually we are also learning this
uh so like the the the the model so the
model the last uh model we uh so I think
here I I have shown like uh two
different models one is like the the
video diffusion and the training for
that is is very expensive couple of days
and cuz uh you know the the memory uh
the memory issues and you directly deal
with like 3D convolutions you know the
best GPU can fit a data like 100 128
Cube and you cannot even like do the
convolutions on data larger than that so
once we have this decoupled diffusion so
uh sorry we we have this latent
diffusion uh the the the training cost
can be sign reduced because we are
instead of like generating the three
like a 3D uh flows where only generate
the the the latent vectors and and
because it's spatial temporal so you can
think this the latent images and uh and
a and previous we kind of overtrained
the model so we find it has memorization
issues so uh you can continue train like
diffusion model for like days or even
weeks and eventually it's going to uh if
you continue train it's going to
memorize things so memorize for train
data so and later we kind of uh uh
reduce the the the the training and and
put the constraint so uh to kind of
enforce the the the models uh uh
basically to reduce the the
memorizationscripture
uh 10 hours and so I I don't I there not
not an exact number in my hand but uh I
can check with my student but that that
is a rough like uh training time um for
now okay well thank you uh next question
is by hungu great talk did you work on
high dimensional input space for example
heterogeneous material properties for
fluid mechanics
Etc uh so
like the distributed input uh parameter
space like in space yeah so for example
topology optimization you use the
density based method every single
element has a the input parameter and
it's distributed in the space and in the
Geo science you know all the materials
is unknown and each element you have to
Define you know yeah it naturally
becomes High dimensional yeah yeah yeah
if uh uh so yeah we we have we have a
download for like a field uh inversion
so um I think uh yeah one of my students
actually here DPAC so he is doing like
more like a solid mechanics um so and
and like a field inversion so it's
entire field like each element you have
a different uh property right so uh if I
I don't know like the the the the
intrinsic Dimension is actually if it's
a match Dimension then the the field is
like a y noise so essentially this this
intrinsic Dimension is is lower than the
the MH Dimension right if the the field
is is continuous so the definitely that
can be diamension can be reduced yes we
have we have been working on that as
well so for example like we um one of
our project we we kind of model the the
the the manufacturing process of the
carbon carbon composite and within the
the open like you you blow the gas and
natural gas there will chemical reaction
and will deposit the carbons and densify
the the porest median um which is the
prey form and so we buil the carbon
carbon composite and we're trying to
model like the this physical process
involves uh like the diffusion reaction
deposition and um and and and uh
currently we haven't considered the the
gas convection but that can be
considered if uh if you have like a high
speeed flow like uh belowing this uh uh
within this oven so uh for that for that
problem so the the
paracity um is a spatial temporal field
and and there are many like um um
spatial temporal field that we we kind
of model the the the basically the
operator between those and we also have
some Physics PD is to describe the
operator so it's actually another like
Hybrid models um I I haven't
particularly done like uh anything with
topology optimizations like using the F
but uh I I I think uh yeah we can we can
discuss if if you're
interested okay next question is by Seer
could you compare the data requirements
of your methods to neural operator
approaches such as
Ceno what what what does c stand for is
a ah probably AO okay actually I I
didn't put uh actually we did we did
some comparison with the with the neural
operators so let me see if I have the
slides so wait a
minute so yeah this is a comparison of
uh this is like uh we actually because
as I mentioned we we are we're using
like a uh uh we're using the neuron as
to learn the operator so from T to T
plus1 this is like operator so it's
essentially it's operator right um so
basically uh we use the same amount of
train data everything is the same
actually this is a collaborative work
with Lulu so some of you know like he is
the first auor of the one
of actually they have done we send the
data to them and they do the Depon net
they have like a variant of Depot and
large and we also test on the EOL and
with the same data set so basically as
as as you can see like uh with this uh
uh this uh PD informations and actually
it does help so uh here what I'm showing
you is is the arrow um on the testing
okay uh sorry both training and testing
uh over the model roll out steps and
this dash line is our in the training
scenarios and the solid light is and the
testing scenarios and you can see it's
pretty consistent for our models and
shows a good generaliz stability but if
you see like the for debonet and they
have a higher arrows um um kind like no
matter training and uh uh and and
testing so for the FN uh for neuro
operators so they have very good fitting
capabilities you can see like this
training they they actually can fit the
data very well uh even like sometime
lower than what we have here but if you
use this train and on testing on testing
scenario in then arrow goes up so it
shows that they have uh kind of
overfeeding so all of those uh models if
you formul this as like next step uh you
are learning The Operators to define the
transition right so all of them will
have the error accumulation some of them
have a very you know serious error
accumulation some does not it's kind of
flat but uh overall you can see it it it
it it it is uh a little better so we
also not just compare the aror but also
like the memory footprint and inference
cost right so for all the neural
operators and you can see the memory
footprint and uh our our approach and
here is is a PD preserved Network so
it's weird PPN but anyway this is ours
so is kind of comparable to all the
other models and also the inference cost
is is also kind of comparable to to the
other models here here the the pin
because we we need a very large Network
to capture the the Dynamics so that's
why the the inference cost of this is
large because the network is large right
so for the other models actually
comparable okay all right awesome
awesome okay I don't see any more
questions in the chat room but I would
like to
ask one questions um so I I'm pretty
fascinated by you you know bringing the
physics operator you know the
differential operator in the
architecture of the neural network okay
so the time derivative terms the neural
OD concept like the recursive neural net
makes sense and the convolutional um
it's basically you know the diffusion
operator makes sense totally makes sense
how about the con convection terms like
the the gradient dot right that that one
but has a direction in it so usually you
know up in the scheme it take account of
the where the flow is coming and and go
how how do you handle that with within
to the architecture neural architecture
do you do you even handle that in
special manner or so I think you can you
can basically encode like the convetion
same way like you you do it and then s
so it's this can be upwind so it's
there's no problem so you can you can
still handle that or you believe that
you want this model to be more data
driven instead of like more like numer
sers and those uh uh those like U
numeric scheme can can also be trainable
so that's that's a flex fle why it's
it's very flexible so for example what I
have show like uh we can basically the
uh uh like have the the convection
exactly uh leverage the existing like
Appo schemes that we used in the in the
cfp solare right so I like I showed in
the um one of the slides so we can
completely like rely on the the the PD
so we actually Implement all the
different num schemes and and our our
our sofware is is not just a simple like
uh numar so actually have those Numark
scheme like the different time stamping
implicit explicit and we also have
energy preserving like this spatial
schemes and
um overall it's it's a finite volume
based but uh uh but we we we we can we
can Leverage The the advanced newk
schemes and to handle those terms but
sometime uh you know uh we wom think
okay probably we can learn a better
scheme from from data uh so uh that that
that is also possible you can just make
those coefficient you can so for example
we have V but we have we have t Vito
those schemes and the the the
coefficient the can be can be determined
using our tradition like num ven scheme
but it can also be kind of data driven
data yeah so uh that that that is
flexible yeah okay cool okay Seer um ask
another question in the chat that is a
very great paper is the code for the
paper available anywhere uh you answer
the questions before uh which paper you
you talking about Seer would you would
you elaborate on
that uh multi- resolution partial
differential equation uh preserved the
learning
framewor I think that that that is the
code is also uh published also open
source okay you can find it in our
groups GitHub um I think there's a link
in in in the paper as well okay sounds
good um any other questions guys it it
has been a
wonderful uh the presentation and
wonderful Q&A sessions yeah I really
enjoy
it if there's no more questions uh we
can just thank Looney is sending sending
the heart to you yeah thank you Looney
all right thank you so much for the Chan
soon it was a wonderful talk and uh we
learned a lot and of um I mean
personally I'm I'm I'm very fascinated
by that architecture concept
so probably I will contact you
separately and yeah and and I'm sure
other people is going to do the same
things thank you thank you yeah I'm
happy to continue discuss with you and
let's see if we can initialize some
collaboration exactly exactly all right
thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you everybody have a weekend thank
you um loing uh no no not Lo the J